hello everyone welcome to part three of
the series
the screencast will be the first of two
or three on neural ir
and in it we'll be exploring the inputs
outputs training and inference in the
context of neural ir
let's quickly start with a reminder of
our setup from the previous screencast
offline we are given a large corpus of
text documents
we will pre-process and index this
corpus for fast retrieval
online we are given a query that we want
to answer
our output will be a list of the top k
most relevant documents for this query
in the classical ir screencast we
discuss bm25 as a strong term matching
retrieval model
so should we just use bm25
the short answer is that we could
but if our interest is getting the
highest quality that we can
then we should probably be using neural
ir
as we will see url ir makes a lot of use
of our nlu work in creative and
interesting ways
the long answer to whether we should be
using bm25 is that it depends
among other factors it depends on our
budget
each ir model poses a different
efficiency effectiveness tradeoff
in many cases we are interested in
maximizing effectiveness maximizing
quality as long as efficiency is
acceptable
let's begin to explore this on the ms
marco collection that we introduced in
the previous screencast
here we'll be measuring effectiveness
using the mean reciprocal rank at car of
and we will measure efficiency and in
particular latency
using milliseconds
this figure here shows bm25 retrieval
using a popular toolkit called ancerini
as one data point within a wide range of
mrr values and latency possibilities
just as a reminder lower latency is
better
and the latency here is shown on a
logarithmic scale
and
higher mrr is also better the higher our
mrr is the better the model's quality
so what else could exist in this large
empty space for now
we're going to see
this space fill up with many different
neural ir models over the next couple of
screencasts
and the central question now and then
will generally be how can we improve our
mrr10 or whatever effectiveness metric
we choose to work with
possibly at the expense of increasing
latency a bit
okay
so let's actually take a look at how
neural ir models will work
specifically at their input and output
behavior
for the purposes of this short
screencast we'll treat the neural ranker
as a black box
we will consider various implementations
for this black box function in the next
screencast
we will feed this neural ir black box
equity and a document
and the model will do its thing and
return to us a single score
that estimates the relevance of this
query to that document
for the same query we will repeat this
process for every document that we want
to score
and we will finally sort all of these
documents by decreasing relevance score
that will give us the top k list of
results
so far this sounds simple enough
but how should we train this neural
model for ranking
this might not be super obvious but one
pretty effective choice is simply
two-way classification
pairwise classification
here each training example will be a
triple
specifically each training instance will
contain a query
a relevant or positive document and an
irrelevant document or a negative
in the forward pass during training
we'll feed the model the query and the
positive document
and separately we'll feed the query and
the negative document to the neural
ranker
and we'll optimize the entire entire
neural network end to end with gradient
descent
using simple classification loss
in this case cross-entropy loss with
soft max
the goal here is to maximize the score
of the positive document
and to minimize
the score assigned to the negative
document
recall that we can get positives for
each query
from our relevance assessments and that
and that every document that was not
labeled as positive can often be treated
as an implicit negative so we could use
this
in generating triples for two-way
classification training for our for our
neural ranker
once our neural rank restrained
inference or actually conducting the
ranking is very easy
given a query we'll just pick each
document pass the query and the document
through the neural network
get a score and then we'll sort all the
documents by score
this will give us the top k list of
documents
however there is there is just a small
yet very major problem
collections often have many millions if
not billions of documents
even if our model is so fast that it
processes each document in one
microsecond one millionth of a second
you would still require nine seconds per
query
for a data set like ms marco with nine
million passages which is way too slow
for most practical applications
to deal with this in practice neural ir
models are often used as re-rankers
models that rescore only the top k
documents obtained by another model
to improve the final ranking
one of the most common pipeline designs
is to re-rank the top thousand documents
obtained by bm25
this can be great because it cuts down
the work
for a collection with 10 million
passages by a factor of ten thousand
because we only need to rank a thousand
documents with the neural model
but it also introduces an artificial
ceiling on recall it limits your call in
an artificial way since now all of the
relevant documents that bm25 our first
stage ranker fails to retrieve
cannot possibly be reranked highly by
our shiny new ir ranker
so
can we do better
it turns out that the answer is yes
we'll discuss the notion of end-to-end
retrieval later where our neural model
will be able to quickly conduct the
search by itself over the entire
collection without any ranking pipeline
but first
we'll discuss a number of neural
re-rankers in detail in the next
screencast